Let's go through these possible answers one by one. To start off, both of these
functions do have y intercepts. In fact, every single exponential function has
a y intercept. We'll talk more about that later. Since the domain of each of
these is all the real numbers, we must be able to plug in 0 for x and get a
valid number for y. Which tells us where the y intercept is. Now, let's move on
to asymptotes. Both graphs have horizontal asymptotes at y equals 0. Neither of
them however, has a vertical asymptote or a slant asymptote. Now it's easy to
mistake these steep parts of the curves for vertical asymptotes. But, that just
goes to show rapidly they grow or decay. These steep sections do not represent
discontinuities, or breaks in the graph, like vertical asymptotes would. In
fact, since the domain is all the real numbers, these graphs are continuous.